Jack Black returns as Po, the world's most
awesome martial arts practising panda.
I'm Jan and this is 27 Awesome Things You
Probably Didn't Know About Kung Fu Panda 3!
To play the awesome Kung Fu Panda Po, Jack
Black says he channels his younger self when
he was just starting out as an actor.
Black taps into his own boundless passion
for rock and roll and acting and uses that
to guide his performance as the kung-fu-loving
Po.
Much of the look of Kung Fu Panda 3 is based
on a trip the filmmakers took to China.
For example, a lot of the architecture in
the Panda Village references what they saw
during their visit to Mount Qing Cheng, an
important spiritual centre as well as a natural
home for pandas.
The filmmakers also spent a couple of days
observing pandas at the Chengdu Panda Base,
a research and breeding centre for giant pandas
in China.
Director Jennifer Yuh Nelson even got to hold
a very sleepy baby panda on her lap!
The movie's creative crew then drew on their
observations of how pandas move and roll to
bring their own animated pandas to life.
To get the right look for the movie's scroll
which tells the backstory of Oogway and Kai,
the filmmakers took cues from a real-life
scroll called "Along the River During the
Qingming Festival", which is such an important
and famous work of art that it's said to be
China's Mona Lisa.
DreamWorks and their Shanghai-based sister
company Oriental DreamWorks worked together
to create two versions of Kung Fu Panda 3
with the same story and characters but with
the characters animated so that they speak
in sync with either English or Mandarin.
More than 200 people worked on both versions
of the film at Oriental DreamWorks, and helped
add to the movie's cultural authenticity,
for example, by advising on new female panda
Mei Mei's costume, and suggesting the inclusion
of traditional Chinese food in certain scenes.
Jackie Chan, who voices Monkey in the English-language
Kung Fu Panda movies, also provides the voice
of Po's biological father, Li, in the Mandarin
version of Kung Fu Panda 3.
Speaking of Jackie Chan, because voice actors
for animated movies typically record their
parts separately, Kung Fu Panda star Jack
Black still hasn't met Jackie Chan despite
this being their third Kung Fu Panda movie
together!
Jack Black actually did some kung fu training
himself for the Kung Fu Panda movies, and
when he's recording his lines for Po's action
scenes, he likes to do a little kung fu in
the sound booth to make it sound more realistic.
Before the Kung Fu Panda animators made their
first movie together, not only did they binge
on a ton of kung fu movies, but they also
took a kung fu class with top wushu coach
and stunt co-ordinator Eric Chen in order
to give them an insight into how the untrained
Po would feel facing someone accomplished
in martial arts.
Animator and story artist Rodolphe Guenoden,
who's worked on all three Kung Fu Panda movies,
happens to have over 20 years' experience
with martial arts, so he's supervised the
kung fu choreography on all the films.
He also continued the animation crew's martial
arts training with his own kung fu classes,
which helped the animators break down how
each character would move, for example how
they should position their feet or their hips.
To create the sound of Po flying and jumping,
the movie's sound editors lined up a load
of microphones along one of 20th Century Fox's
soundstages and then released a taut bungee
cord, which gave them "an incredible five-second-long
sound with an elastic and spongy quality."
When it came to the Spirit Realm, the movie's
sound editors used a variety of Chinese musical
instruments to generate the range of sounds
they wanted for Po's chi or energy force and
the villainous Kai's chi.
But because many of the Spirit Realm scenes
are about inner stillness, they actually reduced
the number of sounds they used and concentrated
on just those sounds that they needed to show
the characters' emotional state.
To produce the sound of pandas bouncing and
rolling along, the sound editors made their
own musical instrument called a "gut-bucket",
which is essentially a large tin wash basin
that they turned upside down and cut a hole
in and then attached a stick and thread.
For the movie's fight scenes, the sound editors
took the characteristic "whoosh" sounds you
hear in classic kung fu movies and expanded
on them, creating more than a thousand "whooshes"
for Kung Fu Panda 3.
The original idea for the movie's jade warriors
came from Pan's Labyrinth and Hellboy director
Guillermo del Toro who is executive producer
for Kung Fu Panda 3.
And the design of the Master Porcupine jade
zombie goes all the way back to the first
Kung Fu Panda movie when the franchise's character
designer Nico Marlet did a sketch of a porcupine
doctor doing acupuncture using his own quills
as needles!
Angelina Jolie is back as the voice of Tigress,
and this time she's joined by four of her
children, Pax, Zahara, Shiloh, and Knox, who
cameo as characters including the panda triplets.
While Knox's co-star siblings have already
appeared alongside their parents in other
movies, Kung Fu Panda 3 is actually Knox's
first big-screen performance.
But the Jolie-Pitt kids weren't the only ones
getting in on the Kung Fu Panda 3 act.
Jack Black's son Sammy provided the voice
of one of the movie's bunnies.
And Dustin Hoffman's grandson Gus was super-excited
to voice one of the panda villager kids when
he visited his granddad during one of his
recording sessions for the film.
Kate Hudson had such fun playing the super-confident,
ribbon-dancing panda Mei Mei that she broke
down laughing at the end of a couple of takes
that actually made it into the final movie.
To cover the sound of her laughter, the filmmakers
had to layer the end of her lines with the
cheering voices of the crowd!
In fact, Kate Hudson felt a special connection
to the movie because her own family had a
feng shui artist who spent a lot of time at
their home and also they often did tai chi
exercises as a family.
Oh, and speaking of Mei Mei, she was originally
going to be played by Pitch Perfect star Rebel
Wilson, but Wilson had to drop out of the
movie when the production schedule was extended.
Hannibal star Mads Mikkelsen was also initially
set to play the movie's villain but bowed
out, after which the Oscar-winning star of
Whiplash JK Simmons joined the cast to play
the villainous Kai.
Like many of the Kung Fu Panda team, editor
Clare Knight has worked on all three movies
in the franchise.
But for Clare, it's been a real family affair.
While making the first movie, she met and
married her husband, actor Wayne Knight, who
voiced a role in the film.
Knight is probably best known as Newman in
the TV comedy Seinfeld and as Dennis Nedry
in Jurassic Park.
While making Kung Fu Panda 2, Clare gave birth
to her son, Liam, who provides the voice of
Baby Po in the movie.
And Clare's husband and son are both back
voicing Big Fun, Hom-Lee, and Lei Lei for
Kung Fu Panda 3.
Remember the first Kung Fu Panda movie, which
opened with Po imagining himself as a hero
so deadly that his enemies would go blind
from pure awesomeness?
Well, there's a cool call-back to that opening
sequence in Kung Fu Panda 3's climactic confrontation.
While making the movie, Alessandro Carloni,
who co-directed Kung Fu Panda 3 with Jennifer
Yuh Nelson, decided to take a leaf of out
of Po's book.
So, when the movie's animators showed him
something he really liked, instead of just
okaying it and moving on, he jumped around
enthusiastically, embracing the kind of passion
Po shows in the films.
And one of director Alessandro Carloni's favourite
scenes in the movie takes place between Po
and his father Li in the Hall of Heroes.
Li tries on a suit of armour and playfully
headbutts Po in the side, which reminded Carloni
of a moment he shared with his own father.
Carloni is really into motorbikes and one
day he and his dad put on motorbike helmets
and his dad started playing around bumping
into him.
Now, who's your favourite villain in the Kung
Fu Panda movies and why?
And what would you like to see happen in the
next Kung Fu Panda movie?
Let me know in the comments below!
I've got loads more Things You Didn't Know
videos, so if you love to know all the secrets
of how your favourite movies are made, do
please subscribe, and check out some of my
other videos!
And if you love animation, I've got a cool
playlist here with interviews, Easter Eggs,
and lots more!
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!